story from timcast.com Georgia D.A puts
police in heightened security amid
potential mid-summer indictment of trump
multiple legal experts believe she will
follow through with criminal charges and
uh I think so but the story was written
by Adrian Norman so I'll throw it to you
what's going on
uh what's going on is the uh
continuation of the what five-year now
Saga we have of the get Trump Mafia who
are looking at any other way to try to
get this guy and stop him from returning
back to the White House I mean we got
the case in New York
um with uh uh
Alvin brag yeah I've got the special
prosecutor in DC who's after him and now
we've got uh you know Fannie Willison in
Georgia and I think they're trying to
throw a bunch of stuff to the wall and
see what sticks and the and the Federal
indictment now where they got his secret
service testifying against them
so we're looking at was it three but
it's probably going to be more we got at
least three yeah New York Federal and
Georgia they are going to indict Trump
and then I guess my question for the
panel is do you think Trump gets
convicted in any of these jurisdictions
the Georgia one is over the I hope like
interference or whatever thing yeah the
2020 election when he was on the phone
with the state officials saying hey can
you find votes so that is a much much
much more serious case than this garbage
in New York absolutely there they're
trying to hit him with Rico charges
right wow yeah yeah it's pretty pretty
serious stuff and again it's uh I mean
if you follow the case at all you know
it's very clear that he wasn't intent on
engaging in any sort of fraud but they
had thought that fraud had occurred
because there were so many anomalies and
problems that occurred in the election
and so many questions that were raised
but obviously you know one of Trump's
greatest flaws and this has been the
case since he ran for office is that
he's very imprecise and he says things
that are allow you to easily
misinterpret what his actual intent is
or intentionally well yeah a whole lot
of context so you know in his Pursuit
for for what was really a sort of a
righteous cause and saying hey you know
we think that there was a mistake that
was made with a certain number of votes
find out what's true what's not they're
misinterpreting the entire tenant of his
phone call his team's investigation to
frame it as though he was trying to rig
the outcome of the election when he
wasn't he was simply trying to discover
whether or not election frauded actually
but I don't think that that matters I
think they will make up any reason to go
after him the the documents thing New
York New York they're going to convict
him
that I just I do not see a New York jury
acquitting Donald Trump I don't and and
this is going to be in Georgia but it's
probably going to be in a more urban
District I imagine when they bring him
down I don't know how he's gonna what
he's gonna if he's gonna try and uh
you know make some argument for a
separate a different venue in the state
or something that's more favorable which
makes no sense and then you also have
the E Gene Carroll thing where I guess
Trump didn't show up is that what
happened do you guys were you following
that no all I saw was that there were
people were tweeting Trump's a no-show
at the Aging Carol uh case she's
accusing him of rape from like 50 years
ago or something and yup they got it in
the courts I I got this you guys might
not agree with us this might be
unpopular but I do think that he was
looking for votes I mean I do think that
he was trying to to to look for
um you know I think he was trying to
pressure
um the state to throw the election to
him
serious case but I mean I don't I don't
I I I will like plead ignorance that
it's not something that I followed very
closely I just know the top lines like
everybody else it just it just
it's just it's well how do you find
votes what does it even mean like in the
worst possible I don't know that he had
a specific plan for what he was trying
to ask of them I think he was just
trying to exert his influence and say do
what you need to do you're the secretary
of state do what you need to do to you
know do what you need to do and I don't
wanna I don't want to know what it is is
basically what are you saying but you're
going to find the votes to deliver
George to me that's what I think he was
trying to communicate
but you reported this out I mean we have
the uh we have the full transcript of of
the call so we know exactly what was
said and again it's one of those things
where Trump is Trump he says some things
that oftentimes can be misinterpreted
and I think that's what happened and you
have liberal media establishments that
run with these narratives and the truth
makes it around the world before the
excuse me the live mix around the world
before the truth heads boots on and I
think there were so many stories that
were being pushed through the mainstream
media
um regarding this particular story that
framed it in a certain way it didn't
even matter what the truth was at that
point yeah get the transcript up yeah
yeah I'm gonna try and uh see if I can
what is this um Trump says thank you
very much hello Brad and Ryan blah blah
blah we're getting 20 30 25 30 000
people at a rally we have a number of
things we have at least two or three
anywhere from 250 to 300 000 bouts were
dropped mysteriously into the rolls much
of that had to do with Fulton County
which hasn't been checked we think that
if you check the signatures a real check
of the signature is going back to Fulton
County you'll find at least a couple
hundred thousand forged signatures of
people who have been forged and we are
quite sure that's going to happen but I
mean that is that is just Trump's
speculation he was wanting them to go
and look for it I saw like in in that
context I'd say this if Trump was like
Hey do a signature verification because
I I bet those are no good signatures is
that trying to swing an election no but
I don't think that he would personally
make that phone call right like the
president of the United States is
calling and saying hey we've got this
reported like you would run that through
somebody else if that was seriously your
goal it just seems like a personal phone
call from the president saying this is
fishing I want you to act I was he's the
president you think he's going to try to
swim an election when everything he's
doing is recorded he's in a room full of
advisors but but it's not just that I
mean what he's what he's saying right
here is
remove it from Top if an individual says
I believe there was impropriety here and
I and I think you should allow us to
check for it is is that above board or
or you know the problem is that like we
could you know this would be like how it
would go in a courtroom where we would
be parsing these words and trying to
figure out the literal meaning and
discern the intent from actual evidence
which is how you should or litigate but
like really this is an exercise just
right here in mind reading right we like
we have no idea but my so it's totally
intuitive but so here's the let me read
you the full quote from Donald Trump and
I'll stress too I think he's wrong about
the fraud narrative
um I do think there's issues with you
know in Time Magazine they wrote The
Shadow campaign you see the article the
shadow campaign to save the election yes
they wrote what they did and how they
did it it was procedural it was through
government it was with deals over a year
and it was shutting down entertainment
which resulted in a mass amount of
mail-in ballots then I think the
question is
if if if how do I phrase this people are
saying it's fraud when in reality it may
be just like lower standards meaning
ballots came in through through mail-in
voting and they were just like this
one's probably fine as opposed to in the
past they'd be like we're going to
scrutinize the signature so this is what
Trump said
he says um let me see him I have to read
more because well whatever he says
you're going to find that they are which
is totally illegal is more illegal for
for you than it is for them because you
know what they did and you're not
reporting it that's criminal that's a
criminal offense and you count that
happen blah blah blah he says and they
were moving machinery and they're moving
it as fast they can both of which are
criminal fines and you can't let it
happen and you are letting it happen you
know I mean I'm notifying you that
you're letting it happen so look all I
want to do is this I just want to find
11 780 votes which is one more than we
have because we won the state and
flipping the state is a great Testament
to our country because because you know
this is a testament that they can admit
to a mistake or whatever you want to
call it if it was a mistake I don't know
a lot of think a lot of people think it
wasn't a mistake it was much more
criminal than that but it's a big
problem in Georgia and it's not a
problem that's going away I mean you
know it's not a problem that's going
away
so this one snippet in context is Trump
saying I believe there was criminal
action in your state and I want you to
actually have an investigation of it and
they just said no to him and he says
look I'm just saying we need to I want
to find 11 000. the context that I see
there is for one I think Trump pushing
the criminal thing was a was a was was
like a heavy-handed threat claiming
fraud was to try and scare them into
actually doing it but
Trump is basically saying to them
I believe there are ballots with bad
signatures I believe that if you
investigate you will see hundreds of
thousands and I just need to find 11 780
of them to win
I mean it's possible that it's both of
what we're describing because he could
have truly believed that he won the
state and he could have truly believed
that there was fraud but the way he went
about but he but he also was
single-mindedly focused on flipping the
state which he says in the statement and
he's leaning on the Secretary of State
in a very totally inappropriate way
saying get in light of all this
do what you need to do to deliver the
election to me because I deserve it
because I actually want it I mean let's
say there's no there's no reason to get
any more votes than you actually need to
win that's actually a legal standard
so so when it comes to these lawsuits
one of the big things we've we found was
that you can't actually file a lawsuit
unless you can justify just enough votes
to actually have one so
it would there's there's an argument
that suing for a number that it's like
to an extreme degree would be would be
deemed like
um gratuitous it's like if if you file a
lawsuit if you can prove one more vote
then you needed to win you have standing
but but my point is this let me ask you
if if you were involved in a a
competition let's let's call it day an
origami competition and then uh you
folded 1 000 paper cranes and then
notice that a bunch of the paper cranes
on the other side you believed looked
suspicious what's the appropriate way to
going to go about checking to make sure
your opponents were on the level if you
go to the judges and say hey I think
those cranes are fake well by your
standard you're saying that you're
putting undue pressure on the judges to
allow you to win
do I in this situation am I somebody who
has you're the reigning Champion power
over the judges though well as the
reigning champion and the fan favorite
you know right but there's a concern
that if you don't win people are going
to be mad but the but this is he's
leaning on somebody who is in his
political party who's part of the
political apparatus that he's the head
of the well he has no power
well the issue I take with your argument
is that if there ever is any impropriety
the only thing you can do is give up and
submit to those I'm not saying that
that's that I'm what I'm saying is that
I think that he was doing something
inappropriate and that he was I think
that his intent was to basically bully
his way into having Georgia deliver to
him I'm not making any like judgments
about reading is a bad legal standard
now what you don't think that mind
reading is a bad legal standard but no
I'm just saying my opinion I'm not I'm
not a lawyer I'm not I'm not arguing I'm
not litigating so the issue is you've
made a determination about Georgia
you've then determined that anyone who
opposes that determination is doing some
nefarious you see my point uh uh well
you're trying you're it seems like
you're asking me to take my standard and
apply it as a universal standard and I'm
and I'm not prepared to do that because
what I'm saying is if I don't know and
don't have the evidence of an outcome I
would expect certification and
confirmation
if uh if a woman goes to the police and
says this man committed a crime against
me I would expect the police to actually
do some kind of preliminary
investigation not necessarily condemn
the guy or or charge him or arrest him
but to be like we'll look into it if a
politician goes to the police and says
that their daughter had been brutally
assaulted and raped and the cops were
like well I'm not going to do anything
about it and the guy says look I'm just
asking you to go and investigate the guy
that is not in my opinion undue pressure
to for for a politician to get some kind
of legal outcome it's literally what
everyone is supposed to do if they feel
something bad happened I think Trump I
don't I don't know what happened in
George I think Trump's fraud narrative
is is wrong I think they explain exactly
how they won with the shadow campaign
changing procedural rules Trump's
argument here is that they were lacks on
voters on voter signature verification
and that if they looked into it they
would probably find hundreds of
thousands I don't know if that's true or
not it's immaterial the issue is they
didn't actually check and the only way
you'd actually seek to rectify a problem
like that is to go to them and say do it
yeah so I my issue is while I disagree
with Trump I don't see any other way to
seek remedy other than asking someone to
do a verification of it well this is
obviously not a hill I'm prepared to die
on but I would say that what you guys
are saying is totally fair
um I think that this is the basis for a
case because like if he if it's as you
say and it's all on the up and up then
that's going to be the defense's
position and if the it's but if it is
the case that he was trying to sway the
election inappropriately that's a
serious offense saying that it's a
serious case unlike for example Stormy
Daniels which is totally frivolous but
let me ask you this what if they do go
back and find actually we found twelve
thousand uh mismatched signatures would
that what would you then think Trump was
acting inappropriately if they can it
would definitely it would definitely
change the context of my thinking about
but they didn't actually go back and and
take Trump's request seriously so then
we'll never know but then so how could
you have a negative view if they didn't
anything you know what I mean like if
they went back and said Trump was wrong
then I'd agree with you I'd be like wow
Trump was totally wrong so uh Trump
trump Trump's argument here was
mismatched signatures and it's like well
I don't know maybe they didn't chat I
mean the the fraud stuff I certainly
think is wrong that was weird that was
like dominion and stuff and the CIA and
all that was out of the question yeah
but arguing about lack's signature
verification policies something totally
different yeah so your point is since it
didn't amount to anything
then there's no real it's not it's like
well it's it's like look if you have two
people who are standing before a judge
and one saying acts and one saying why
I think it's inappropriate to be like
how dare you ask that question person a
when a judge should be like okay show me
your evidence and then the person will
be like here's a list of things I think
justifies my claim and the judge should
then be like person B do you have a
counter claim to to refute this and then
if investigation is like if there's
probable cause then a court should be
like okay we're going to Grant a
signature verification request to see if
these claims are accurate I mean it's
sort of like okay to take an extreme
example if you were to if you're an
elected official and you went to
somebody and you're like you're like
listen you know
uh it seems like you you might need help
with your daughter's private school
education and like like does that of
interest to you and oh by the way I'm
looking for this particular favor and
you're saying everything's short of you
know directly offering a bribe you could
you could have the same litigation
around whether this was entire maybe he
was just trying to help out or is the
the person's daughter who's going to
private school you know and like like
you it would come down to this mind
reading thing or you could look at the
totality of the circumstances and say
this looks a lot like like a bribe but I
think that situation it's easier to make
a quid pro Crow right because Trump
doesn't say specifically I could do this
thing for you yeah he just said hey I
think this thing happened will you check
and they said no and then he was like
are you kidding me and they're like no
go away right and then your your
attitude is like how dare Trump ask for
for a remedy to a perceived problem if
if someone so there's there's a few
questions around this I mean if we're
dealing with matters of public interest
then I don't think the Fourth Amendment
plays a role if the government is is
involved in something then the
government has a right to publish to the
people the results of a search I don't
see how it makes sense that I'll put it
this way if someone came to me if if
someone did the cops and said you know
Tim Poole stole my Spoons the cops would
be alike we'll we'll talk to him and
we'll see what's going on and then if
they can't get any probable cause to get
a warrant too bad so sad have a nice day
and that's it however if it's a group of
police officers are carrying a bunch of
spoons and then one person says they
stole my spoons and another person says
actually they didn't you're lying and
then a person calls the police chief and
says I I you look just look in the
police locker room and if the spoons are
there that proves it I don't see that as
undoing or like if a politician did it
it doesn't matter if the fact the fact
is we're dealing with an election the
smartest thing in the world to do would
be for Georgia to be like you know what
Trump so that we can throw out all
confusion we absolutely will do the
check and prove to you you're wrong
thanks watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time